[Musique]
le maghreb synonyme de chaleur de
couleurs et surtout d'odeurs sa cuisine
reflète la même magie avec ses épices
à montréal dans l'épicerie de calais de
sefrioui originaire du maroc nous sommes
séduits par les effluves de son razel
hanout mélange des pistes variées
très aimée au maghreb au maroc ça
représente quoi cette épice là c'est
l'appellation la note
normalement c'est censé être le summum
des épices la halle le mot race en arabe
veut dire la tête dans la tête des
épices donc l'extrême tout les bons et
pis on sont mis en valeur chaque
marchand fait son propre mélange si vous
faites par exemple son épicerie au maroc
vous allez trouver sans recette
différente on utilise beaucoup dans les
plats sucrés salés
mais le plat par excellence pour mettre
à l'honneur les parfums du razes el
hanout et l'amour via un plat de moutons
mais je t'ai lors de la fête annuelle
l'aïd el kébir la plus importante des
fêtes islamique
le chef imad eddine mac régis choisi
plutôt les new pour nous préparer ce
fameux plat phare de la cuisine
marocaine
on voit que l'usiné bronzer à c'est
quand même simple à très très anciens
vous le trouvez ou votre mélange parfait
je te dis moi j'en ai acheté ma mère
saviez-vous
et là est ce que c'est une de vos
recettes qui va cuisiner qu'elle croise
la route c'était didier libye les radios
ces bleus là les i c'est elle qui m'a
montré ça on trouve son équivalent chez
des indiens le garam masala et chez les
libanais les cette épice se mélangent
sert d'ailleurs à la base de la recette
de khalid je prends un kilo de cette
épice qui se vend sur le marché
je veux les personnes âgées waouh ça
c'est puissant comme aux gens ce qu'ils
y aillent à le claude giroux qui est
très dominant la dent donc je rajoute
100 g de cumin
il y à la base le cumin le carvi la
coriandre la cannelle et le gingembre
maintenant pour parfumer
on va rajouter deux clous de girofle de
la muscade moulu d'acorda bonnes pour
que chacun puisse faire varier sa saveur
khalid va compléter sa composition avec
du poivre blanc du fenouil pour la note
aigre-douce un peu de curcuma et de
l'armoise ses épices venu de la
lointaine asie ou voyager au fil des
siècles jusqu'au maghreb
voilà vous allez nous donner une idée de
ce que c'est bizarre mais ça crée aussi
côté tunisien ils vont mettre du port de
cayenne pour être plus piquant dans sa
recette de mort aux ja iman eddine
ajoute au razz el hanout de la cannelle
du poivre noir et du gingembre la
meilleure façon d'utiliser des épices il
faut tories fit un petit peu c'est
d'ailleurs moi je vais prendre un peu d
huile d'olive avec les oignons avec les
épices en entente horrifié les épices ça
dégage le goût
je mettre tout de suite et souris
d'agneau
je vais mouiller tout de suite sinon ça
va coller
safran c'est ma réponse après une heure
de cuisson on ajoute les raisins et les
amendes et monde et pour un autre quatre
heures sur le feu on va les laisser
mijoter le secret du saas et la cuisson
très basse à basse température
en fait c'est la cuisine orientale et
donc comme ça ça remonte maintenant vous
allez voyager à marrakech au maroc
l'avion devait être tellement déchiré
parce que s'étendre ça c'est le 5 heures
des puissances
ah oui ça sent tellement bon là puis
autant razal hanout quand on sent
directement les épices c'est très fort
c'est très puissant
oui autant le site du com parfois oui
bon
merci à vous d'avoir pris dans la
cuisine et puis merci à votre mère merci
beaucoup à vous c'est un peu plaisir